- [Instructor] Joey is training for a
hot dog eating contest.
The person who eats the most hot dogs
in 10 minutes is the winner.
If r is the number of hot
dogs that Joey can eat
in a minute.
And N is the total number
of hot dogs he eats
in the contest.
We can write the following equation.
So this makes sense.
He eats a total of N hot dogs.
And the contest is 10 minutes.
So you divide that by 10.
So he's gonna eat N hot dog in 10 minutes.
And so, yes, this will give you the number
how many hot dogs on
average he ate per minute.
If Joey can eat six and
four-fifths hot dogs per minute.
So they're saying, r
is six and four-fifths.
How many hot dogs does he eat during
the 10 minute contest?
So they're saying, "Hey,
what is N going to be,
"right over here?"
And so N divided by 10
is six and four-fifths.
r in this situation is
six and four-fifths.
That's how many hot dogs
he can eat per minute.
Now there's a couple of ways
that you could tackle this.
You could say, "Hey,
some number divided by 10
is six and four-fifths."
And so you say, "Well that number must be
"six and four-fifths times 10.
"And six and four-fifths times 10 would be
"60 plus eight, or 68."
So that's one way you could do it.
And you're essentially
multiplying both sides
of this equation by 10.
The other way you could do it,
is you could just try out numbers.
And that usually takes a lot longer.
But at least it will
give you the sense of how
the equation relates.
And, especially 'cause
they have choices here.
It's not a bad idea.
Obviously the ideal one is to just
think logically through it.
Hey, if something divided by
10 is six and four-fifths.
Then 10 times six and
four-fifths is going to
be that something.
And that's how you can get 68.
Or, if you want, you could
try out the different numbers.
Look, 65 divided by 10,
is only gonna give you
six point five.
That's not the r we're looking for.
56 divided 10 is gonna
give you five point six.
Not the r we're looking for.
68 divided by 10 is going
to give you six point eight.
Or six and eight-tenths.
And six and eight-tenths
is the same thing as
six and four-fifths.
So 68 works.
45 hot dogs, you divide that by 10.
You're gonna get four point
five hot dogs per minute.
So all of these are completely legitimate
ways of doing it.
The important thing that you
understand this relationship.
And you understand how
these variables work
with respect to each other.